[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
previously on model lifestyle know what
this what is this I have no idea what
this is
worms have you seen that before him this
is not for sensitive viewers alright so
these are the side dishes are we having
to get what are the
[Music]
yeah which one the most lively one verse
one yes yes the big yes do you want me
to try and chew it don't you so I just
arrived here at the job and they want me
to show you a little bit so that's what
I'm gonna do right now I like my beard I
don't have to shave
okay so shake for the job and now just
to tell you guys who start modeling if
you come into a job the first things
that you normally see is clothes so you
see the clothes over here this is what
you have to probably wear and then you
see some shoes lying around and then the
next thing you see is the makeup room
they have a very small man Capri
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hola
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody knows my something interesting
[Music]
spicy Korean food
[Music]
cheers guys what are you eating there
kimchi so we got some spicy beef here
and then we got some pumpkin and egg I
thought it was cucumber but they say no
it's not and then well I don't exactly
know what the other stuff is fish thank
you photographer is helping me out so we
did inside shooting and are we gonna do
outside shooting we almost done is the
end of the day a little bit tired but
they arrested the curious here is the
last few shots
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]